Trascrizione: Riccardo Sasso
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Ogni oggetto della nostra
esperienza quotidiana
ha alle spalle una lunga storia evolutiva.
Il web è nato nel 1991,
ma la ricerca che ha portato a Internet
è iniziata nel 1969.
L'RNA è una molecola scoperta nel 1961,
studiata come possibile terapia
nella lotta contro il cancro
durante gli anni '70:
una ricerca che, però,
non ha ancora compiuto un pieno successo.
E ancora, sulla Stazione
Spaziale Internazionale
da ben 20 anni si eseguono esperimenti
di combustione in assenza di gravità.
A cosa serviranno?
In un futuro non ancora definito,
a progettare veicoli - aerei, automobili -
in grado di consumare meno carburante,
e quindi di avere
un minore impatto ambientale.
Potremmo fare molti altri esempi,
perché la storia della ricerca scientifica
è costellata di invenzioni
che hanno visto la luce,
e ci hanno cambiato la vita,
molti anni dopo essere state concepite.
E anzi, questa sembra essere, proprio,
la regola non scritta della scienza:
esiste un tempo - necessario
e mai definito, ma è sempre lungo -
perché dal libero pensiero,
e dalla curiosità di un ricercatore,
nasca qualcosa che poi
incontra davvero una necessità,
qualcosa che arriva
a risolvere un problema
che magari si presenta
in maniera improvvisa e fatale.
Esiste una costante,
nel lavoro di chi fa ricerca,
ed è l'incessante inseguimento
della propria intuizione.
E anzi, se chiedete
a 100, 1000, 10.000 ricercatori
di qualsiasi ambito,
di qualsiasi disciplina,
tutti vi diranno la stessa cosa:
che poter seguire quell'intuizione
è il più grande dono
che la vita ha loro concesso.
Per loro, è irrinunciabile.
Seguono alla lettera
quello che diceva Socrate:
"Una vita senza ricerca
non è degna di essere vissuta".
Perché il ricercare è strettamente
collegato alla libertà di pensiero;
e perché il ricercatore, come tutti,
vuole lasciare un segno di sé.
E non ha altro che il suo
indomabile genio, per dimostrarlo.
Non esiste il colpo
di fortuna, in ricerca:
esiste il talento,
che incontra le opportunità.
Ed esistono, invece, giorni e notti
di interminabile lavorio nascosto.
Fatto di tante intuizioni:
ma anche di vicoli ciechi,
di binari morti,
di inversioni di rotta.
Fino, poi, a unire i puntini
in un disegno coerente.
Il ricercatore ha davanti a sé
un percorso per lo più ignoto:
ma se gli è nota la dimensione spaziale
data dalle sue conoscenze,
dalle sue competenze specifiche,
meno nota è la dimensione temporale:
anzi, proprio non gli interessa.
Lui si concentra sull'avanzamento
puro della conoscenza,
senza una applicabilità immediata.
Lui sa che ciò che cresce lentamente
mette radici profonde.
Il ricercatore è incorruttibile,
non insegue esperimenti
che gli diano ragione:
anzi, confuta egli stesso
le proprie teorie
per fortificarle, per renderle più solide;
e quindi, riproducibili e condivisibili.
Quando, nel 2017, a Michele, Pietro e me
è venuta l'idea di fondare un'impresa
sulla base della nostra idea di ricerca,
sinceramente non avevamo idea
della dimensione del nostro viaggio.
Sì, partivamo con il nostro bagaglio
dato dalle nostre conoscenze,
e le nostre competenze
nell'ambito delle biotecnologie
e delle nanotecnologie;
ma avevamo, anche,
tanta incertezza, tanto timore.
Ma una consapevolezza:
che la nostra azienda, da appena nata,
doveva subito esprimere
tutto il proprio potenziale.
È nata libera,
ed è nata letteralmente in un sottoscala,
nel garage di Michele.
Ma libera fin da subito
di poter crescere in ogni direzione;
e di poter raccogliere,
e rendere rigoglioso,
ogni più piccolo seme di sapere
che avessimo incontrato
lungo il nostro percorso.
L'abbiamo chiamata Nanomnia,
perché il nanometrico
è l'ordine di grandezza
di tutti gli esseri viventi,
al momento del concepimento.
In sintesi, cosa facciamo?
In sintesi, noi "creiamo ricercatori".
Sì, nel lungo termine
noi creiamo ricercatori;
nella realtà di tutti i giorni,
creiamo nanoparticelle:
ovvero microscopiche,
nanoscopiche strutture -
nanoscopiche vescicole -
nelle quali inglobiamo
principi attivi di varia natura:
possono essere farmaci, cosmetici,
agrofarmaci o altri composti industriali.
E inglobandoli, incapsulandoli,
li accompagniamo, veicolandoli,
durante lo svolgimento della loro azione,
fino al loro target specifico,
che può essere una pianta
o un insetto patogeno,
un microrganismo,
un tessuto del corpo umano.
La particolarità è che il guscio
in cui le inglobiamo
è completamente naturale,
completamente biodegradabile
e completamente privo di microplastica.
Volendo fare un paragone,
che sappiamo già essere sproporzionato,
con quei ricercatori
che dagli studi sulla RNA
come molecola terapeutica per il cancro
hanno poi aperto la strada
al RNA come farmaco nei vaccini,
anche la nostra storia
ha un inizio diverso.
E dagli studi di nanoparticelle
utilizzate per malattie neurodegenerative,
abbiamo poi declinato la nostra tecnologia
ad un altro ambito,
dove c'è urgente bisogno
di processi di precisione
e di misure a basso impatto:
che è quello dell'agricoltura,
degli agrofarmaci.
Ci siamo inseriti nel solco tracciato,
prima di noi, da qualcun altro.
Quello che facciamo noi
lo faceva già qualcun altro, prima di noi;
ma con altri processi,
altri metodi, altre tecnologie -
soprattutto con altri materiali, plastici,
che quindi non biodegradano completamente,
che generano un residuo,
che poi sedimenta nel terreno,
entra nelle acque di falda,
finisce nel cibo che consumiamo
e quindi, nel nostro organismo.
Ma il fatto è che nel 2017,
quando noi abbiamo fondato Nanomnia,
noi non sapevamo che avremmo contribuito,
con la nostra tecnologia,
ad un processo trasformativo;
non sapevamo che della nostra
tecnologia "plastic free"
di lì a poco ci sarebbe stato
davvero bisogno.
Sì, perché due anni dopo, nel 2019,
l'Europa, nell'ambito di una serie
di politiche ambientali,
ha emanato diversi provvedimenti,
secondo i quali, nell'arco di pochi anni,
potranno entrare nel mercato europeo
soltanto quei prodotti che risponderanno
a una serie di requisiti
in termini di salute,
sostenibilità e sicurezza.
E tra questi requisiti,
anche l'assenza di microplastiche.
Noi questo non lo sapevamo,
quando abbiamo fondato Nanomnia
due anni prima:
noi l'abbiamo fondata sapendo di avere
qualcosa di bello, di buono in mano,
di buono per tutti.
L'abbiamo fondata in anni
pieni di intuizioni:
ma anche di vicoli ciechi,
di binari morti,
di tante inversioni di rotta.
Anni in cui eravamo, peraltro,
in estremo anticipo
rispetto alle strategie di mercato,
rispetto alle politiche ambientali
e tutte queste dinamiche che, ovviamente,
noi da ricercatori non conoscevamo.
Ma un certo punto, alla nostra porta
hanno cominciato a bussare
le grandi aziende, i grandi player:
quelli che detengono grandi quote
dei mercati di appartenenza.
E che della nostra tecnologia,
priva di microplastiche, avevano bisogno
per mantenere i loro prodotti sul mercato.
E a quel punto,
siamo diventati strategici:
siamo diventati "la" scelta.
Non esiste il colpo
di fortuna, in ricerca:
esiste il talento
che incontra l'opportunità.
I valori in cui avevamo creduto
hanno generato valore
per altri più grandi,
molto più grandi di noi.
E l'eco di quanto avevamo creato
ha potuto espandersi
con una risonanza molto più grande
di quelle che erano le nostre aspettative.
Prima eravamo piccolissimi,
ora siamo piccoli;
ma senza una prospettiva lunga e ampia
non avremmo mai potuto resistere
nelle fatiche di fare impresa,
anche quando queste
sono diventate insostenibili.
Ovvero, quando lo sforzo
era molto più grande
delle nostre energie
e delle nostre risorse.
Questa sera siamo qui
a parlare di sostenibilità:
ma secondo voi, come può essere
la ricerca legata alla sostenibilità?
Io me lo sono chiesto,
e per me la risposta è semplice:
perché come la ricerca non dà risultati
dall'oggi al domani,
così pure la sostenibilità
non si improvvisa.
Una scelta sostenibile
non dovrebbe mai essere compiuta
in condizioni di urgenza, di emergenza:
anzi, dovrebbe essere prevista
con largo anticipo,
ben sapendo che l'uomo è,
per propria natura, un consumatore.
Divora e consuma tutto ciò che trova
sul proprio cammino,
incurante del domani.
La ricerca, invece, genera sostenibilità
perché è lungimirante.
Perché sa guardare avanti nel tempo,
sa individuare e prevedere
i possibili sviluppi di una situazione;
magari mitigarne,
o sfruttarne le conseguenze.
La sostenibilità generata dalla ricerca
è la capacità di elaborare
un pensiero nuovo,
di esplorare, perseguire nuove vie,
verificate da una sperimentazione
rigorosa e approfondita.
Per passare dalla scala di laboratorio -
che è una scala ripida, faticosa,
al buio, stretta ma ineludibile -
per trasferirsi poi su larga scala,
a beneficio di tutti e per il bene comune.
Ma per generare questi frutti,
per generare sostenibilità,
la ricerca va sostenuta.
E come?
Con educazione scientifica,
educazione alla visione,
educazione all'onestà intellettuale.
Gli ultimi anni ce l'hanno insegnato,
la ricerca, sia di base che applicata,
deve avere un ruolo guida
nello sviluppo di una cultura sociale,
al pari di chi governa una comunità.
Con saggezza, con senso di responsabilità,
con lungimiranza,
che è quella capacità
di prevedere il futuro,
di preoccuparsi per il futuro.
Ma è quella virtù che permette all'uomo,
e al ricercatore in particolare,
di leggere gli eventi
in relazione all'azione degli uomini.
Saper elaborare il presente,
e orientare le scelte future,
anche se lontane.
E in questo senso, allora,
la lungimiranza è anche "larghimiranza":
la capacità di vedere
non solo davanti a sé,
ma anche attorno a sé;
la capacità di abbracciare
soluzioni nuove, diverse,
punti di vista e prospettive diverse
per il bene comune.
Questo ci insegna
l'esperienza della ricerca.
E non serve essere dei colossi, per farlo;
non serve nemmeno essere i più importanti.
Ma serve coltivare la libertà,
il dono gratuito della scienza.
Serve far sciamare la conoscenza:
e senza gelosia, senza mai centellinarla,
disperderla e restituirla a tutti.
Per il bene di tutti.
Grazie.
(Applausi)